this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
oh look at that
I have got one of the tallest animals in
the world and this animal is trying to
feed from one of the long trees and
already the animal has started showing
some unusual behavior for the first time
I'm seeing the giraffe breaking some of
the branches in order to access the
leaves a very very good afternoon and
welcome to the beginning of the
afternoon Safari
I am Sydney from Grandma cozy and I am
traveling with Davey who is my camera
operator this afternoon we are going to
try by all means and give you the best
wildlife experience ever my plan for
this afternoon is to look for the
spotted cat and don't forget that this
is an interactive activity you can
follow us on Twitter hashtag safari life
you can also follow us on YouTube chat
stream so I'm just going to move now
little bit much closer so that we can
have a lovely exciting
so this giraffe looks very interesting
at the moment as it is displaying some
of the unusual behaviors
so is just walking by himself I cannot
see other giraffes here because mostly
giraffes you find them in a group a
group of giraffe together it is called a
cops of giraffes you can also call it a
kinder Garten
of giraffes look at that this is a
lovely sighting so this animals can grow
very tall so the male's such as this one
can go up to five to six meters and if
you look at the legs they can grow up to
1.8 meters and the amazing part is that
the legs are the same size as the neck
in terms of the length that is something
amazing so you can see the spots they
are much very dark the male's
they have got dark spots whereas the
females they've got light spots but both
male and females when they are getting
old they both dominant dark spots so
when they are old you must consider the
following you must have to consider the
thickness of their horns so if you look
now this one by looking at the horns you
can see that this is a male they all
they look very much thick so the females
have got a thin horns and the females
they've got hairs on top of their horns
whereas the males don't have hairs on
top of their horns in fact the giraffes
doesn't have horns what we are seeing
there it is something which is called an
oxy cone and oxic hole is just a bone
and skin and a horn is something which
is consisted of a bone and a keratin so
you can see that this giraffe is getting
tired of looking up all the time
so now let's go to a David who got one
of the largest land mammal I am here
with one of the tallest land mammal
David has got something very interesting
by the Maasai Mara at the moment hello
everyone and welcome to the Masai Mara
trango Game Reserve in Kenya and I'm
trying to look at the commonality those
similarities between giraffes and
elephants and I would only say they'll
both or they're both happy bows and
elephants will be both browsers and
grazers and giraffes being more of
browsers I don't see any other
commonality or similarities between
these two animals a very warm day or a
very warm afternoon we have in the Mara
and as usual my name remains David and
with me on camera today is Manu and a
very good afternoon Manu you all very
welcome and remember always our safari
drivers are very interactive your
questions or your comments are very
welcome as you sure you can use hashtag
Safari live on Twitter and we'll always
be very happy to answer your questions
or share your good comments like seeing
elephants and seeing zebras in the
background they are a pretty warm
temperature after noon as I was saying
before 29 degrees and 85 degrees
Fahrenheit bye bye I'll say the oldest
elephants I know that leave or I know
that still live could be about 60 years
or 65 years of old I think that so it
was your question there's a female just
walking across there and very majestic
walking through the savanna
very good I think the oldest elephant I
have known that I would say still alive
is in National Park in Kenya could
Amboseli National Park and I think she's
about 66 years of age 66 years of age
and the average age or lifespan of
elephants is about 65 so going in 66 to
70 spooly not bad we have always
compared ages of Ellie's or elephants to
that of human beings to me it feels a
bit cold as much as about 29 degrees or
85 degrees Fahrenheit because these
elephants would always give us an
indication when it's very hot when they
keep flopping their ears but you notice
it's just walking picking some either
leaves or plants on the ground there
those two around us Tamid mound and
being around tamil mine it shows that
particular area of that mound it's very
house you notice the green the grass is
much greener and the same case to this
cow and her calf another tamid mount and
if you look carefully the grass is much
greener than the rest or the neighboring
area because thomas do a pretty good job
when they leave well apart from myself
and Sydney there's another gentleman who
would like to say hello to all of you
indeed I would David and that's always
nice to hear from David up in the Mara
now you can see that there is a rather
McCobb image that is about to present
itself there lies a dead neeyala female
I'm afraid you can see the bite marks to
her neck and so this is a very
interesting situation because this niala
was killed probably in the early part of
today and so you'll see as we come back
at school very whole it's down in a
drainage line and it's very very close
to where husana and ting Ghana were this
morning my name is Tristan as David
mentioned on camera I've got a sins oh
and it is a very warm welcome to all of
you the soft you know I hope that you're
gonna really enjoy your afternoon
promises to be an epic one because
this kill was made by Tandy this is not
secure footing on and husana and that
tree on the other side of where I am
over there so that one that's tall over
there
that is where Hasan and ten Ghana are so
that's where they're killers they
apparently are both still there
Tandy somehow has managed to kill this
antelope at some point without the two
of them even realizing it and his fit a
little bit but she's not sure at the
moment she's probably lying up somewhere
in the shade we will try and find the
two of them now but the two of them
apparently after we left because some of
the trainees said sure for a while and
they followed her all the way around and
she walked with Clallam all the way
around back to this kill so
unfortunately for her she is going to
probably lose this Dingaan there's no
ways at a hundred and fifty metres 100
metres from where their tree is that
Tenggara is not going to find this and
his nose is not going to lead into it or
husana for that matter but we have four
leopards on two different kills within
the space of 150 metres which is
absolutely ridiculous it really is a
phenomenal kind of situation and not one
that you'd really see all that often now
you can see that that niala is very very
fresh so for those of you that are
squeamish is probably a good time to
look away but if we go in onto the meat
itself you'll notice that the meat is
still a very bright red color now we've
had a lot of wind over the past few days
and that would have dried that out very
quickly if it had been an older carcass
so that was killed during I think well
Prince reckons that it was during the
day today
it could have been early hours of this
morning before ting gonne arrived at
that kill and Tammy when she bumped into
these two boys was actually coming back
towards her kill and just bumped the two
boys and that's why I maybe could
elaborate ran off but either way it was
killed early hours of this morning or
even during the course of the day today
between the two the safaris
[Applause]
kill six no so given that's I mean if
she did kill its after we saw her this
morning well then the heiner's have all
been sleeping you know it's a middle of
the day I eNOS don't move around all
that much and they didn't spend time at
the carcass rehearse on and ting gana
was because when ting Hassan and Tandy
had their little altercation early and
the one honey that was there ran for its
life it just tucked and ran as far as it
could to try and get out of there I
think that hyenas still running when it
heard all the growling and hissing and
kind of snarling that was going on and
two lipids bear barreling down towards
it and so just ran off and so no they
haven't found it but tonight they will
if neither or any of these four leopards
doesn't tree this kill then most
definitely we're going to find that I
eNOS will steal this unfortunately but
I'm very surprised from waiting Ghana
was in the tree that he didn't kill take
place and then come in and actually take
it for himself now interestingly enough
we've actually got some little white
Tristan Houma tracks that are bouncing
around very close to the carcass and I
wonder if they would actually go and
feed off any of the insects that could
be close to the carcass itself you don't
really often see birds close to a lipid
carcass because it's quite a dangerous
place to be
they're right above it right now so you
see they are sitting right above where
the carcasses kind of bouncing along on
the trees wonder if they just Hawking
little insects that maybe are landing on
that carcass itself which is a very cool
thing to to see you not often you
actually kind of can hear them but you
can hear that clicking sound that is
them as they sort of forage around to
this particular area yeah there we go
very cool right now on that note we're
going to City area try to see if we can
just find a visual of Tandy and Columbia
because we didn't get to see Claire
lumber this morning and so while we do
that it sends you back across to Sydney
who I think is still with the very tall
spotted creature
Oh Rizzo
look at that I'm still here with the
graph and I just hear Tristan was
enjoying a lovely sighting with a helmet
Shrike those kind of birds can be very
much interesting and is a very
interesting vendor traditional story to
do with them if you see them it means
next week we are going to eat there
so it means SSI eat and drink so getting
back to the giraffe you can see that
this giraffe is now moved to another big
tree now the giraffe is under one of the
marula tree which is also recovering at
the moment so it's quite very difficult
to see the giraffe now because he's
using the shade from the very same tree
so it's eating the shade at the same
time so this animal was just ruminating
while standing there it was very
interesting to see the giraffe taking
back food from the mouth not a leopard
AG laughs they do drink water and how
they drink is interesting yes they do
concentrate on lot of moisturize the
leaves that they drink water and when
they come to the water holes this is
what they are going to do they go and
they must have to bend the legs go down
and get water after that they see
procedure they must have to follow
they must have to shake the neck when
they're shaking the neck is when they
are opening the valves before they go
down for drinking they must have to make
sure that all the valves they are
plugged so that the blood doesn't flow
to the brain otherwise if the blood
flows to the brain the giraffe is going
to lose the life
so look at that so this animal is got a
very long tongue
Rosalind that tongue is got about seven
neck bones which are there in order to
support them when they are feeding so
they never get tired and they use again
the very same necks for fighting
purposes so in other words these kind of
next they are very well adapted to face
up and for them in order to strangle the
others when they are fighting for the
females as well so look at how that
giraffe is walking you can see that the
body is moving swiftly so that is what
the giraffe wear it means one who walks
swiftly so this giraffe is just moving
very quickly from one tree to the next
which is now giving us a proof that
these trees they have got some
substances they are using in order to
chase these animals so now let's see the
giraffe doesn't have wings to fly but
David by the Maasai Mara has got a
flying bird on the ground at the moment
let's see what species got we just had a
few seconds ago over but let me just
find out first him I'm seen and Nigel
and it just should fast a little bit and
this nature was very difficult but
for we have a nature here the tapping
you've never seen during the day this
would be a fastener to judge see during
the day it's anyone who keep boy
just hold for one second okay let's see
where the money is going to put you the
frame this is a little odd right there
and is an idea very difficult to see
during the day you only see them at
night man who do you suggest
back up more fodder let me just forgot
for a bit she's just hiding that grass
it's just jumped up and she landed there
let me just move forward a little bit
and see that maybe let's just see how
and she's right there you see how
they're right there you see Oh No
yes max they're excellent well done oops
she just took off but anyhow that was an
edger that all is very difficult to see
absolute giving up for one more view of
and you only see them at night night
jars
yes and scrub hey ours
you really see them during the day but I
just think this is a lucky day for me I
don't know what that luck translates
into and I don't know what Chinese but
may get this could be the mounting night
jar and I don't know with their projects
alpha is watching project alpha will
always get me when I get stuck and one
thing I know for a fact this is an idea
and you only see them at night they're
very nocturnal birds and you notice how
she blends in very well there I don't
want to be very loud neither do I want
to get my bad book or my party just to
flip the pages to know who she is
I also cannot see her very well but one
thing it from the size of her eyes you
can tell you the night gent they
normally have large eyes now so you can
see the beak it'll have some whiskers
which they'll use to catch flies at
night and they always have a very
special tool that have something like a
brush because they use that too unless
you say the right leg or the left leg to
just groom themselves and just to align
or realign their fellows so if you get
an idea and you watch carefully on one
of it is toes it has been modified to
something like a brush and they will
only use that to or brush just to align
the feathers cause if you
ha carefully she looks very nice Kress
100% I mean until she jumped up grace I
had not seen her so she blends in
perfectly well and I will tell you grace
she'll be there for the rest of the day
and she'll only become more active at
night when she goes out to feed on flies
or sometimes where you get them on the
road or some open areas but it's no
grass warm-up well oh yes nyjah's will
always nest on the ground in general
they do nest on the ground but sometimes
depending on the particular species of
Naija you might see them on trees on
branches and they usually blend in very
well and at times you might mistake them
for part of the tree so you'd imagine
this particular that we are seeing here
on a branch of a tree or at a branch you
know at any very a tree that branches on
one side it would definitely look like
part of that tree in general they nest
on the ground and I think is usually
much warmer for them the only guess I
would have here for this one is the
mountain and nightjar not 100% sure but
I'm just guessing this could be the
mountain nightjar apart from that one
feather doesn't look very kept if we
look at her carefully everything looks
very streamlined I'm walking back to
very many areas very good I'll be more
than happy Casti if you know all of you
viewers could just tell me who you think
she is but I've given you the most
important clue James Richard jumbo and
how are you and always a pleasure to
hear your name and yeah it could be a
swamp night yeah very very good guest
after this because I don't want to be
very loud I don't want to give flippin
my book my buds book how we look but yes
James Richard it could be a possibility
I was saying earlier I am trying to walk
back to the very many years I saw a
night jar during the day and that year
is not coming
man when is the last time you saw major
in the day money saying the last time he
saw net jaw during the day was today
thank you very much man who planning in
very well there and she'll be there as I
said maybe the rest of the day and only
coming out at night I'll just try and
move forward one meter if she doesn't
fly out fine if she does well and good
and see even a little more hold on right
there mother
James recharged does this help so you
can see the big eye on her and then look
on the whiskers I was talking about yes
because I says this is awesome and for
me it's pretty good because at night
when we see them we see them you know
using the infrared to see them during
the day in natural light I think it's
pretty special so it could be the swamp
Niger James Richard could be right it
could be the mountain Nyjah what
conspiracy you can see it's the big eye
and the whiskers was talking about if
you look on the beak so you will see
sometimes and that's very good man I
thank you very much they'll fly opening
the mouth
magic dragon with that yes you're right
what we do we really drive off-road and
of course we are always very careful and
my guess is maybe she could be lying on
her eggs but apart from us we have a
challenges magic dragon daily God
through wood we'll be like animals like
Jacko's or bat-eared foxes or similar
lizards who will always cup all snakes
even come and feed on their eggs yeah
you've got a good point there will
always to make Villiers try and make
sure we have very minimal impact when we
are offloading and right now I am I'm
just on the road and she's just on the
side of the grass and until she flew up
magic dragon I would not have seen her
completely and as he just landed there I
think this to me to be a sign of good
luck I might have a great drive today
man did you feel like me man who says oh
yes we might be having a very smashing
afternoon on the drive to see a night
during the day and this time apart for
the first few times she jumped up and
down yes Cassie agree with you this must
be one of my greatest drives because she
just laid down there and she just took
cooperative game was the best views I
open and you can see it's not like a
round eye and I think that way it makes
it easier for hard to see at night it's
like over shift and at one point I'm
going to open my book and have a look at
who she is
hello there in general you see them you
know in once not in pairs you don't see
them in pairs when they're meeting and
after meetings done they go separate
ways and in that position you would not
even know there could be bad right there
Nyjah thank you so very much
I'll let you have some Loeb peace there
just rest and hopefully this could be
sign of great drive for me and Manu this
afternoon
let's see what that mates translate into
how exciting some of these birds like
the water thick knee nightjars owls even
at night when we see them they are
always on the move but to see that like
during the day and she stayed there for
us that was pretty special
and I really want to thank her excellent
just driving or slowly trying to a big
plan today is to look for lions
yesterday I see the sausage tree pride
and I'm hoping I'll be able to see them
today and as I do that I think my other
brother is in a tree my videos
we live right i radioed not working very
well hello everybody good afternoon
welcome to well this end of the Sun set
Safari we are on Torchwood where the
radios are not so fly
but we're on Torchwood because of course
there are some lions here Brent Leo
Smith came looking here with his friend
Jamie Patterson and we are just trying
to now relocate where the Lions are they
apparently have killed a buffalo which
is very exciting
let's just hope I can actually find them
just through here sorry the game drive
is now very loud in my ear something
else had to tell you oh yes of course
well you can talk to me like you've been
talking to everyone else hashtag spoiler
chat seen on YouTube all that stuff
now it should be right here sir have you
got them Sebastian can see them there
are Lions there is a lion there are
Lions Minnie there is a buffalo the
Buffalo is no longer alive but very did
this is very exciting
we just interposition that thelma the
thermal drone is in way of being killed
I believe that the lion has just come in
though
you
you
well unfortunately it sounds like James
has got a few little gremlins there
hopefully I'll get this is great
exciting
we came up boards what an ending are now
but once a show said anywhere it isn't
to to see if tanyon Colombo might be
hanging around with the two boys
unfortunately she's not here neither is
the Cubs so it's just for sana that's
lying here ting understood in the tree
we ain't it probably in all likelihood
just quickly sort of hand this off to
Sydney ours just coming up here in case
the two of them might be hanging around
with the two boys and almost just trying
to kind of distract them somewhat to be
able to sort of keep them away from
their kill Oh bless you did you have a
big sneeze
he's such another story.this now he's so
busy sleeping he hasn't even noticed
that there's an Impala right here that
he could potentially hunt so just behind
me over there is an Impala that is
really kind of not really in any way
knowing that these leopards are here but
nervous cuz the wind is blowing so much
but if he actually just lifted his head
and looked in that direction he would
spot that there's an Impala day of
course if he killed it he would end up
not having anything because Dingaan is
going to steal it so you know I suppose
it doesn't really kind of work for them
and I'm 99% sure that Tandy is going to
lose a kill to one of these two boys
this afternoon or this evening
for now the both of them are fairly sort
of sleepy and fairly tired and are not
really doing too much like I said
Tenggara spent his entire day at that
tree which can't have been comfortable
at all he really must have been
struggling quite a bit up there I'm sure
he's going to be quite stuff when he
eventually does come down but like I
said we're gonna leave this with Sidney
I want to try and see if I can find the
two girls and so I'm gonna be driving up
and down all over the place to try and
see where they have gone and so while I
do that and go off and try and find the
two girls let's send you back across to
David in the Maasai Mara he's driving
about
Tricia and Wow talking of Tandy talking
about Paradise has I think the next job
might have brought us the good luck or
the good omen I was talking about and we
have been or have been fine been lucky
to get the sausage tree pride this is a
sausage trip right and this is one of
the males in that coalition that roams
around this is it right of course
males do not belong to price but they
belong to a coalition but before long
man is going to show you the females
that we saw also a few seconds ago
freaking the tails under some bush
orange lift Croton and when I'm talking
about the sochi tree pride I'm talking
about females definitely the males do
not form the pride but now if you look
at the pole of this one chairman here or
this guy you can see it full of flies
and blood that definitely sees this a
bit of this crime scene around and not a
mushroom war time but they brought down
a wildebeest I'll be trying to identify
who exactly the tree right in there and
it's come how this marriage in charge
because few seconds he as they got here
when the females rose up towards the
keel and this bill just pushed it out
and you can see he must have been
digging into it will be finding out will
try to get a little bit closer because
my signal is a bit if you know but let's
first go coast to Sydney as maybe a
reposition myself and it'll be better
place to keep narrating
I look at that I have got a very brave
impala trying to charge a leopard now
decided to run away and she charged that
leopard a few times and the leopard was
just not interested to entertain it so
that was a very brave Impala
she was just alarming and coming closer
and charging and decided to run away you
can see right next to me I have got a
very much in next cat this is or Zhanna
is not only mood of hunting s that
Impala was not that very far away from
where Hosanna is at the moment so he
looks very tired maybe he's got
something in the stomach I just have to
see nicely if he's going to change the
position we might be able to see if the
stomach is full or not maybe that will
be one of the reasons why it did not
entertain the impalas must close so you
can see that now he is getting excited
so you can see that he does things at
his own time it doesn't want to be
guided by the impalas interest now you
can see that he is interested on
something
maybe is the very same Impala or else he
have spotted something else
I am very much interested to see what
this animal is fascinated by and I am
not alone here by the siting I do have
some other guest who has just arrived
now don't get confused when hearing some
camera clicks James their cats they've
got to sleep much of their times because
of the following one look at what is
doing now so he's showing you now it has
been very much hot and is trying to cool
the brain temperature in the head
so this case they spend much of their
time sleeping because they've got to
give their digestive system much time
after eating something but apart from
that animals such as cats they are much
more active between dawn and dusk so
these animals when they wake up between
dawn and dusk they must have to be
energetic and strong enough for hunting
activities so you can see that if these
animals are not relaxing much more
during the day chances of them to take
something during the night they are
going to be very much slim so you can
see that Osama is now moving much more
deep maybe he's just looking for some
shade so I'm just going to reposition
now and see if we can have a better
sighting from a different angle so I can
see now he is slowly moving down towards
they all the drainage
so he's positioning here I can see that
he is standing while listening to
something
you can see that our asana is now pretty
very much relaxed and my apologies for
the inconvenience is due to the lack of
Internet
Alya I am still here live with a Hosanna
I can see that Hosanna is not doing
anything we are going to have some time
with asana maybe somewhere around here
we might also be lucky with Tigana
as we heared earlier that they were all
two together in the same area so I am
going to be looking around here to try
and see if we cannot find King Ghana Oh
Dave has spotted him is right up in one
of the trees day well that was a nice
spot is quite very difficult to see look
at that
he has very much camouflaged doesn't
look like an animal in there you can see
that the tree is still very green and is
very much pushy with quite a lot of
branches so it means now Kangana and
wasana they just all together at the
same sighting this is interesting
so it seems like ting gana is not having
something up by the tree there I'm not
seeing anything unless maybe it's I
didn't because of too much branches so
you can see that was Donna
so you can see that our sauna is just
waiting and every time was on ice
waiting like this is when they see
clearly and by which has been taken down
by him and ting gana arrived to come and
take over maybe somewhere up by this
tree is where the food is hiding and
because of that we are going to have all
these cats together
I wanted to see what exactly is
happening but it's not moving at all so
now let's go to our Tristan maybe
Tristan has got something interesting at
the moment I do indeed we've got
something that we haven't seen in a
couple days but are slowly making their
way back you can see just ahead of me is
a small group of buffalo bulls now I
wonder if these are not buffalo bulls
that were potentially chased by the
Akuma pride all the way from Torchwood
to here because they are just slowly
kind of keeping their way along and we
haven't seen any signs of Buffalo but if
the King Coons have grabbed one maybe
these guys are ones that have kind of
run off from that area but nice big
Duggar boys that are all together it's
not a herd structure that so as far as I
can see the tracks so far just indicate
that it's just a few boys together and
they are all boys and even though it's
you know five or six of them you know
that still doesn't mean that there's it
goes in amongst them so this would be
quite a formidable grouping to go after
if the increments that bring one down
out of this well they've done a
phenomenal effort to be able to do so
because these guys are big they are
strong and they are powerful and the one
on the far left is an absolute monster
he's got huge huge horns compared to all
their it so there is their straight in
there is look at the size of that guy's
horns really big I mean that must be
probably I would say close to a meter
from one sort of curl to the other they
are huge horns and it's so nice to see
these guys back again while it obviously
makes kind of bushwalking those things a
little bit more dangerous it really is
nice to have them back around we've
really missed them and hopefully they're
kind of presence in this area is going
to mean that the Lions are going to
spend a lot more time in and around
humor than what they have over the last
little bit now you'll notice most of
them are grazing at the moment and they
will be very excited because in amongst
these sort of dry thickets there is
actually green grass that is starting to
sprout up and so it's very difficult to
see but maybe if since it comes quite
close to the vehicle there's a little
patch just on the right-hand side here
so somewhere in this
you'll see that there is actually some
green grass that is coming out between
the sort of clump they are straight in
from there
I'm not down a little bit there we go so
you see the greenery it's in amongst
that dry brown grass now for Buffalo
that is exactly what they're looking for
they really need that kind of green lush
new growth and that's from the little
bit of rain we've had that's now
starting to come through and that's what
they'll be targeting so the days of
browsing and eating dry horrible grass
are almost over they're now going to be
able to start eating nice greenery that
you see there so they'll be very happy
animals and you'll find they're gonna
walk along and just heads down and feed
because this wind is blowing as heavily
as it is all the animals are a little
bit on edge they are all kind of
watching and stopping and looking and
it's really kind of difficult conditions
for these guys to be able to survive
they unfortunately have got a deal with
this wind gusting like this and it's
gonna hide the pizzas noise when they're
moving as well as their scent if a
Predator is downwind from these guys
they are going to have absolutely no
idea because of how strong this wind is
blowing and so it's a predators dream
the kind of conditions that we've got
today and it's probably why there's
ended up with three different carcasses
sprayed across the area so the lines of
got a carcass and then four different
lipids on a carcass is because of
weather that we're having Rosalind most
definitely in the many recorded cases of
Buffalo killing lions it's not something
that doesn't happen I've personally seen
two different lines that have been
killed by Buffalo and the one was an
adult female that was completely
disemboweled by a buffalo its horn got
stuck between its legs and he just threw
her and as he threw age he kind of
ripped through her stomach and and
killed her like that which was really
quite some things not not a nice thing
to see at all but yes Buffalo do kill
lions it does happen you often find old
sick lines do you get hurt from time to
time and they will get unfortunately
kind of maimed by Buffalo and also lion
cubs so if Buffalo find a lion cubs
hidden they'll trample and kill them so
they are very dangerous to lions even if
even though Lions had
there is a lot of danger that it's
involved in acting one of these guys you
can imagine those horns can do some
serious damage if you're on the
receiving end of them now they'll see
that they're slowly kind of drifting
away from us I think they're going to be
hitting over the boundary we're at close
near the Buffalo boundary we just came
around hiding the road to try and kind
of see if we can find Tandy until 11:00
and so while we do that the since you
back up towards David in the Mara and I
think he is with some lions and I'm
pretty sure they wouldn't mind being
latched on to the back end of these guys
as a potential meal well once in a while
we have seen sometimes prey fighting
back and not once we have seen Buffalo
is trying to go for the Lions which oh
hi les which would be chasing them or
trying to bring them down now I doubt
this would happen to this particular
male lion here which shows all the signs
of being mighty and strong and you can
see how he is panting having eaten not
sure how many pounds or kilos of that
will beast that's not very far from
where he is now this particular male
comes from Coalition of lions that we
call the sausage tree for those who are
joining us now there's a particular
pride of lions that you call solitary
pride and they're males that will be in
this particular territory where we are
and this is one of those young males is
this male and another male but now let's
find out if Hosanna could be up to
something
look at that I have got Hosanna now
trying to stalk one of the hyenas who
has just arrived in the area and he's so
very much camouflaged and he's just flat
the hyena is just in front of him less
than 15 metres away from Hosanna
anything can happen at any time here now
so you can see that now the hyena is the
Heine has just spotted husana you can
see that the IANA is trying to avoid him
now look at that he's still following
the hyena and he can see the hyena from
the top of the termite mound it's very
much interested on that Heine and that
Irina is avoiding horse on by all means
not even checking what is happening
behind so you can see that now husana is
going in between the branches and he's
using his paws you know that camouflaged
but now the hyena is looking it's
looking back and her son has just
stopped when the hyena is moving is when
Astana is also taking a move so I'm
going to just keep following and see
what is going to happen here so maybe we
might be lucky and see them chasing each
other so it seems like
hasanah is building quite a lot of
strength now in order to defend himself
against these hyenas so it seems like he
gave up now as I can see he's just now
looking at the hyenas which is now going
away
so you can see that now he is just a
sniffing the ground that is where that
ina has gone past
so look at that
so it is very much rare to see this kind
of cats challenging the hyenas whereas
there is no food they are not competing
for anything the food is high up by the
tree with H in Ghana who is now feeding
at the moment
so you can see that this cat is sniffing
on the ground and after that is opening
the mouth to try and confirm about
something so I'm not too sure what this
investigation is all about
so I can hear quite a lot of bones
breaking from the tree behind me which
is waiting Ghana is what I'm going to do
now is that I am going to leave asana
and go back so that we can see what in
Ghana who is feeding at the moment from
where I am I'm just hearing quite a lot
of Bones crashing from the Impala which
has been caught by asana earlier on so
it seems like we might have a better
sighting waiting on is so you can see
that these sightings are just very close
to each other not very far curses these
kind of animals they the cats mostly if
you can check
they don't really eat these hyenas
but cannibalism is practiced by some of
these animals but I've never seen a
leopard eating a high number sometimes
yes they can when they are too hungry so
you can see that there is some meat we
can see from here which is much more red
but it is very much difficult to see the
actual animal you can see the synth
things are happening there
so I can see that some piece of miss
there now falling to the ground maybe
husana is gonna he's gonna get something
at the moment so I can see that now and
wasana is making his way back and while
hosana is making his way back let's go
through the Maasai Mara and see what
David is having at the moment seems like
David is enjoying something well
leopards could do anything at any time
and especially when two cools off that
will not be the case with the lions and
our male here is still looking very
snoozy just enjoying the sleep apart
from the flies that we see on his front
right paw which are happy trying to
digest or eat the blood that is left on
his paw there but he doesn't seem very
concerned by that so I was talking
earlier that this coalition or the
lioness is around here we'll call him
the sausage tree pride of lions or
lionesses the reason for that the
particular trees in the Mara that you
can associate trees those trees are very
iconic just like the phone trees and we
have followed this pride for very long
for a long time we have always found
them going on top of those trees either
to look for some nice shade because such
trees have very huge leaves and the Box
all the tree branches have very smooth
box and when they climb on top of them
they are always very comfortable and
then the reason that should make this
lionesses like the one you see they are
going on top of that tree is to go away
from the Flies if there's so many flies
you know in the grass who like for
example where she is they will always do
that and that's how they got the name
the sausage tree pride remember this is
a very interactive Safari that you know
we do both here in Kenya in the Masai
Mara triangle and in South Africa you
always welcome to ask questions
should you have some nice comments to
give you can do that using hashtag
Safari life righty we now move down
again to South Africa to Tristan indeed
and you can see little Columba is
feeding off the carcass with much glee
and relish so where she was just now
when we came here I have absolutely no
idea we couldn't find her at all don't
know where mom is can't see her sitting
yeah I'm sure she's watching from a
distance some way in the shade just
making sure that this one is safe the
problem is is with tenganan husana where
they are they will be attracting hyenas
because of the smell of that carcass up
on that Ridge as they start to come down
this this side they might move in this
way if wasana chases them and they might
then steal this so this little one is
eating quite a bit I'm short and he's
not far but I'm hoping that she'll be
able to get down and hoist this kill
long before hyenas arrive because
otherwise she's going to lose out but
little Columba it looks so small in
comparison to seeing the boys haven't
seen her in a while and she's still very
little in comparison to you know the
likes of Hassan aunt in Ghana you forget
just how small these little females are
when they're around the year old she's
got a lot of growing still to do but
look at the size of her tummy she's
eaten a lot I think these two must have
come off for kill already this morning
when we saw Tandy she was quite full
already she didn't look like she had
eaten off this carcass and so I wonder
if these two weren't sitting on a kill
since the last time brains saw them and
then they went off and Tandy we saw
yesterday afternoon killing that scrub
here and then they made another kill
here today so very cool to see but the
fact that we're sitting within 150
metres of two male leopards we've got a
young female here her mother must be
somewhere close by as well means it's
just ridiculous for lipids on two
different kills in the Black Sea in the
space of a hundred meters is almost
unheard of and so we are seriously being
spoiled on our lipids this afternoon or
this morning and this afternoon should I
say just lately in general actually and
I'm so excited to catch up with her I
haven't you know in such a long time
it's really good to kind of see her
going about her business and how kind of
dwarfed she is by that niala is
quite funny now you'll notice you can
see her mouth is moving quite quickly so
you can see there she's actually not
chewing at the moment as much as she's
licking she might be licking a lot of
the blood up them they will consume a
blood and they will lick up blood as it
contains a lot of water and it allows
them then not to have to what to not
have to go towards things like a dam or
a pan
she's also probably got herself a good
chunk of meat and sometimes you'll find
they'll actually win the caucuses like
this lap a blood that's pooled and an
eel in the cavity of this particular
animal so she's really going to town
though since she that is so cool so glad
we've managed to catch up with her and
that she's actually here now I just hope
the naughty hyenas don't steal from
these two because they if it's not
hiding as I suppose is he's going to be
a male lipid they're pretty doomed
either way when it comes to skill the
only saving grace that these two have
got is that the wind is coming the
complete opposite direction to where the
boys are so if they were the other side
of the boys the scent would be blowing
right onto them and I can pretty much
guarantee that they probably would have
lost it by now already but the way the
wind is blowing it's blowing from them
to I mean from the boys kind of it's
growing a cross between them so it means
that unless they walk in line with this
carcass southwards from where they are
they'd probably won't pick up the scent
and with the amount of wind that's
blowing the noise of her eating is not
going to be easily heard at all and so
she should be able to get away with the
time hope that they'll get away with it
but you know knowing ting Garnon and
husana both of them have noses unlike
any other cats and and will probably in
all likelihood pick up that scent and
kind of figure it out and move this way
we're in for an epic evening either way
and you know as that Sun starts to sit
in that caucus that ting ganas on starts
to diminish so we might see a kind of
interaction between all four of them as
well as hyenas in the mix it's going to
be a really kind of special fan of
afternoon and so it's a hold on to our
seats and see how this all planned pans
out it might all just fizzle out into
nothing and everyone just stays in their
respective places but it could also just
be a spectacular kind of afternoon of
sort of lipid to chaos which would be
very very cool but I'm surprised still
can't get over how much smaller she is
then what her son is for sauna you know
I forget how he's grown I remember you
know last year he was a little boy now
you kind of says just because I just saw
him just now and used to compare him to
the size of Colombia and he really is
that much bigger than her he is he will
dwarf her now and I mean he even talks
Tandi Yuka saw this morning those of you
that were watching and those that were
into well basically we had Hasan and
Tandy side by side and you could really
see the size difference already in in
Hasan and Tandy and so with alum Bay
Hill really kind of dwarfed her
completely but so cool to see this at
all and she's got so much kind of sass
to her i I really thoroughly enjoy her
Tandy must be driven mad by the subtle
cab ever since the first time we've
spent time with this little cab it would
just do its own thing and kind of very
seldom listen to mom and so I've
thoroughly kind of enjoyed her attitude
towards life and just a general kind of
disposition and who sort of about
herself she's gonna be an interesting
female she's gonna be a tricky one in
many respects because she doesn't come
out all that often is very seldom we
just find her sitting by herself she
doesn't really like to be seen other
than you know if mom is around or on a
kill like this so she's gonna be a bit
tricky when she gets older especially if
she spends time kind of yeah I'm hanging
around this area we're gonna have our
hands full I think with her but I'm
hoping that as she kind of goes and
grows older and hopefully gets in
towards motherhood she'll calm down a
little bit to not be so full of beans as
she has been over the last year
at all of a theoretical yes I mean she
could because she should be going for
Laverne and you know kidneys and hearts
and those kind of things but I suppose
maybe she's gotten maybe a kidney they
already and she's just kind of eating
away around all of that sand opening
everything up whatever she's got she's
thoroughly enjoying so I can't see
nicely what it is exactly that she's got
you might even be eating a fetus you
know that which would be a bit kind of
macaw by now so you never know what's
really inside there's that stomach
cavity hasn't really been opened
properly you can see a bit of the
intestines has been pulled out and in
bed of the stomach has been exposed but
there's still a lot kind of going on
inside they see she's actually opening
the cavity as we speak and so I wouldn't
be surprised she she's still getting
towards the liver and towards you know
the they the heart and and all of those
kind of internal organs that are so
tasty so she'll get there and the
problem is is her belly is already full
so it's going to take her quite some
time before she actually is able to eat
much of that meal I mean she's not
exactly skinny so she's gonna not be
able to eat that much and I doubt a nice
very skinny either than pretty short
Andy has got a fairly full belly as all
brains agreed with me so actually what
happened this morning is that we kind of
traded with print and and the Chinese
and they came out and they followed
we'll just sat and watched as everything
played out in the hope that's you know
everybody would settle and then managed
to follow it Andy down here and find her
with the skill so you know between
everybody it was a real team effort to
be able to find this carcass it was kind
of just a a long vigil that took place
from when we saw tiny on this morning
safari all the way till now somebody is
kind of been with these cats which has
been quite something to be able to spend
that much time and that just goes to
show that sometimes it's rewarded if you
just kind of put a bit more effort in
and to be able to see these things so
like say the entire Safari live team or
guiding team particularly spend time
after day to try and kind of keep these
sightings for all of us which is which
is always good
can see she's every now and then disgust
she's got that instinct down that way
every now and then she just stops
listens around kind of makes sure that
she's not being ripped on by tripped up
on by male hyenas or lions or anything
like that and that's gonna stand there
and good stayed particularly in
conditions like this because it must be
very difficult to hear what's going on
right well we're gonna sit with little
ammo we're gonna figure out where Tandy
is while we do that though we're going
to send you a cross all the way to the
Masai Mara with David and apparently
he's got some very snoozy sausages who
I'm sure are replicating Tandy there was
having the Leopards Christian which is
much more active than my lioness here
which is just flicking you know yeah I
know doing much very typical for
lionesses or lions just to sleep and see
both of them there or just flat-out
slipping
just like the male and this explains
what I've always said that it's not only
the males people of Syria like when you
say kings of the jungle and males
because they sleep for so very many
hours but for me it's both males and
females
now this particular price or the may
around here they got a kill here of a
wildebeest that they have hidden very
well in that particular bush that you
see there if you look in the slight
opening there's something dark on the
inside and this bush is what you call
the orange live Croton this are
wildebeest to them that's the kill I'm
sure could have been you know the
brought one down during mid-day
now there's something very special about
this particular bush that we could
orange live Croton the leaves and those
green leaves you see there they do not
attract any flies and lions I think time
immemorial have known any time they'll
bring a kill there any time they will
lay down there they are granted not to
be disturbed by those irritating flies
like you know the saucer flies or the
big ones oh the most creatures and any
why's that will come to them will be not
of much concern so you see the male is
not very far from that Bush just like
the females just laying on top of that
truck and I'm sure he's getting a bit of
warmth from the rock he's laying on
remember this is a very interactive
Safari should you have any questions or
comments like saying Wow
how nice to have him just sleeping there
please send it through John I would say
Lions have the largest canons Lions have
the largest currents if you compare to
all the big cats that we have of course
the good leopards we also got Jaguars
and we got Tigers Tigers which are much
bigger than lions as much as we don't
have any Tigers in Africa but I'll say
take us if you look outside Africa to
have the largest canons but looking at
the cuts but we are in Africa to the
taste and they will need them because
they need to subdue
when the Bing just choking them or
chokehold when they suffocate them
before they start you know eating them
you can see him just punching them
sorry about that crash cart everybody we
do seem to have some signal issues well
these are not the Inka Homer pride as
you can see they that is horse Hannah he
is of course Belote in ghana which you
all knew and I have taken over the
sighting from Sydney because Sydney is
gonna go to the Lions and see if he
can't find some signal there with Wendy
if he can't he'll probably come back
here then we do of course have our is
ABC 3 show coming up at 6:30 this
evening 6:30 that is Central African
time and we will be live all four of us
from here whoops and Sebastian's there
sorry about that and so we need to try
and maximize what we have Tristan's
obviously very stable with Tandy and
Columba we are sitting here with the two
males and it would be great if we could
have those lions but I have a hammy
Deutz that even Sydney and Wendy will be
able to get signal at the line but he
will be there probably in the next 20
minutes or so and we'll keep you posted
quite a remarkable day has been had by
all here I don't know if Tristan told
you I think he did but the the trainees
were sitting here all day babysitting
the leopards which was great for them
and for us and quite astoundingly
you know they've they've arrived here
pretty well I mean they've got some Bush
experience and we'll lots of biology
behind them but they've driven in you
and they're suddenly they've got fall
efforts within about oh I don't know an
acre of each other quite astounding
that's a pretty good turnout
dissenters I think that ting Ghana
allows Hosanna to remain because he's
his son now obviously that's not a
particularly detailed answer what I mean
by that is that he doesn't feel a threat
from Hosanna that's one of the reasons
the other reason of course that Hosanna
is a young male and is not showing too
much in the way of territorial behavior
he is doing that sort of marking
behavior what people have called marking
he hasn't called yet
he's still a bit young for that
obviously but you know I think that
marking behavior that spraying of bushes
inaccurate as it often is is just part
of growing up it's you know it's like
I'm trying to think of an equivalent
human example when a boy hits puberty
and starts to become a man he does some
things that men might do you know he
tries to shave and cuts himself he what
else can I say that a man a boy does
that a man will do a lot more of he
becomes slightly more aggressive and you
know he tries to test himself against
other boys as his testosterone levels
raise but he's not really being a man
he's just kind of learning or feeling
the first flushes of being a man and I
think it's very similar here well sauna
has obviously got the hormones of
adolescence now coursing through his
body and so well some instincts
sometimes he he feels the need to spray
on the bush I'm not sure he really
understands why he's spraying on a bush
it and anything he's necessarily trying
to mark territory so that's what I
think's going on there but the other
thing about relatedness here and I don't
think that this is conscious at all I
think it's entirely unconscious but even
if hasana
was to mate with a Lepidus in his
father's territory his father would
still be passing on his genes indirectly
and that's why there is this tolerance
amongst related animals that may be
especially male animals
may otherwise be in conflict so that's
my answer dos Santos might be entirely
rubbish it's all based entirely on
conjecture and a bit of reading but
mainly conjecture Tristan is just across
this rather deep river
indeed I am I know exactly James is I
saw him just now briefly through the
thicket so I can't really see him
anymore but you can see now that Tandy
has come in instead of Kalama she Clara
moved off a little bit not far and then
tiny came and took her place and is now
tucking in to feed but when I was saying
earlier that she's got a full belly you
can see it quite clearly now if you look
at the size of that tummy in comparison
to you know how much is actually been
eaten they've definitely come off a
really decent meal in the last little
bit what have you single I'm sure she's
very nervous of the boys arriving in
this area now since I can you come to
the tree right next to us because well
there is a liquid it's also a very cool
little lizard that's cruising right next
to us it's very very close there it is
it looks like a little bushveld lizard
that we've got and straight in straight
in straight in straight in there it is
in the middle there slightly up a bit
there we go straight there we go you can
see they camouflage that these little
guys have got isn't that cool
you often find them these particular
ones moving around in areas like this
where they able to go up onto small
trees like a tambuti tree and they can
kind of camouflage and go into the
cracks underneath the bark and hide out
there but very cool to see I know
there's a lipid around but sometimes you
got to look at the smaller things that
are around you too
it's always nice to have kind of up
close views of lizards because generally
we see them from so far and we don't
really get to see much about them and
this one is Goodwin there's one that is
very close and I mean that is as close
as you could ever get towards a lizard
on a vehicle I mean it's probably less
than a metre from where I'm sitting
right now on there it goes off the up
the tree I'm pretty sure it's gonna go
and try and find a little hideout spot
to stay nice and safe yes be careful
there's two lizards around and petite I
mean - like lipids or
in particular Colombo who will chase
little lizards I'm pretty sure she does
all the time and it's probably
unfortunately taken quite a few of these
guys you know Tanya still feeding she's
quite alert at the moment I'm hoping yes
it does look like a good of its tail was
kind of disappeared oh it's just got a
bit of a new tail it's growing after it
lost it they often find it's a certain
lizards do you lose their tails as part
of the defense mechanism so the tail
drafts often stays wiggling and it
allows them to move off while the
predator is preoccupied with the wiggly
tail now tiny won't have that ability so
in something like I mean arrived today
she's not gonna be able to do that
instead she's going to have to use all
her strength to try and drag it up a
tree and I honestly don't see any really
nice trees for her that are going to be
easily climb a wall and easy for her to
put this carcass I'm very surprised to
see that she hasn't dragged it to a bit
of a different spot where maybe it's a
little bit more hidden or you know out
of the way but for now she's kind of a
there's a lot of trees around you might
be thinking I'm absolutely mad because
you can see trees all over the place but
they're all straight stem timber teas
with very few nice comfortable v's for
this carcass to actually hang in so I
would be very surprised if she's sort of
picked any of these they're not ideal
trees for it to hang they might actually
be one towards the back end if he might
be able to get into which you see luxury
look at her she's kind of licking in the
sort of bottom part of that carcass so
not only will she be getting rid of meat
but she's also licking up all that
pooling blood that's sickling in that
area and like I said before if you're a
little squeamish it's probably not the
best time to look you know lipids when
they feed particularly on a new carcass
like this you can often see a lot of
kind of blood coming out of the carcass
as well as you know a lot of the
internal organs but well done girl how
you have managed this I'm not quite sure
she's somehow managed to bring this down
without the attention of both the boys
depends I mean I've seen aggressive
males and aggressive females I I must be
honest more aggressive females and males
but
it depends on the upbringing in where
they come from and their experiences
females obviously have a lot more to
lose in a male lipid in terms of you
know male can often just run away and
and move off where is a female lipid
she's often what cubs which means that
she's got to be able to try and kind of
look after those clubs and and that
causes her to be a lot more kind of
defensive of her area and makes sure
that she is constantly on the the sort
of offensive if she's trying to defend
those cubs and try and keep their you
know whatever predator is at bay now
since I says he can spot the little baby
are the fetuses in there there we go so
exactly what sins was trying to say now
is looking at the thing that was saying
that this pinata might be pregnant and
I'm sorry if you are in our squeamish
you nearly need to look away now because
that is a little baby niala that hasn't
been born and it's quite well-developed
it's really got its stripes and that's
what she's busy pulling out and I said
it earlier that it looked like that
stomach was very big and I'm afraid
there is a little baby now and that's
always very very sad to see these things
as much as it's great for our lipids to
feed it's it's very very kind of
difficult and you have to watch them
feed off little and borne animals it's
it's never a very pleasant thing at all
and you know it's it's unfortunately
part of life and we're gonna see a lot
of it over the next couple months you
know as the impalas and the allas and
many of the animals gear up to have
their babies in time for summer so you
sort of start to kind of see these
sights and believe a lot of you are
saying oh no and it's not very pleasant
at all it's not something that any of us
really like to look at especially a
little baby a as well-formed as that you
know that is kind of got fur it's got
its stripes already so never nice
that's all but it is nature and it is
the way things can go in yes cuz she can
always that omid imagine would be quite
interesting to see if little claw lumber
tries to hoist that
it may be a good learning sort of curve
for her to be able to hoist that little
niala fetus up now I wonder maybe the
Sanada was actually prepping to give
birth because that little fetus is very
well formed it is big big big big and I
wonder if maybe that's why this Nuala
was in here as she was ready to kind of
give birth and be able to you know and
maybe that's why she was on her own and
Tandy was able to find her kind of in
the subtle Carly because I doubt that
Andy dragged this carcass too much it it
doesn't look like it was dragged very
far at all and so shame so it's tough
like I said it's never nice to see tiny
little baby animal like that but in his
nature like I say and it is part and
parcel of life arches as you know it's
one of those things that unfortunately
does happen right now while we search in
watch this rather sort of dark scene
unfold let's send you back across to
David up in the Mario's got a lots more
of a happy moment as he sits with the
sausage free pride as they rest in the
beautiful beautiful Masai Mara well it's
very true Tristen what would happen Oh
Hawaii respect the wilderness animals
will always kill for a purpose they'll
always kill to feed themselves and for
that reason that's how nature is meant
to be in the meantime I am just enjoying
the sunset or the Sun going down because
my lions are still very flat but I'm
sure as it cools off they're gonna wake
up the rise and shine but in the
meantime watch that sunset how beautiful
to see sunset in the savanna or in the
Mara Triangle in the backgrounds there
you see that escapement and that is the
escapement that forms one of the arms of
the Mara triangle for those of us who
have joining us now who have never been
with us before so the famous mass
similar game our triangle has three arms
that's one of it the older escapement
and then there's another um that's the
boundary between Kenya and Tanzania and
the other arm of the triangle is the
Mara River which many wildebeests who
will be cursing or having crossing for
the last few weeks or months during the
migration how beautiful is that son as
it goes down just watch it for a couple
of seconds with all the beautiful colors
in the world that you think of very good
and yeah crossing the final control says
that is just amazing think of any nice
color in your life yellow peach black
white orange bit of blue black or the
colors as human beings would love slowly
as surely Sun has given us a very good
sunset here in the Mara triangle
some clouds hanging up there definitely
an indication of Noreen the last few
days have been having rains almost every
afternoon we've gone to the onset of the
short rains in Kenya very good job man
how peaceful is that well I mean
thinking about the night jar we saw alia
and James recharge I know you you an
expert yes number two and I'm looking at
how good is that manner is that good you
love the dashboard is that okay very
good
I mean debating of the night Joe we saw
earlier and I've been flipping through
the pages
oops sorry about that off my book and
they look to us for the swamp nice job
from James Richard and looking carefully
the distribution did not show it to be
where we are in the Masai Mara so in the
meantime not 100% sure I'm settling on
the dusty ninja but of course we can
beat on that Ron little father all
righty
where are the lions Manu are they still
there sorry about long yeah still sleepy
and I just found out we got three in
total here not very close to where we
are we got the the oldest female in this
group that's called a kink tail and we
shall be seeing it much later but that
move lion tomorrow triangle to other
Lions in South Africa
so you can see that I've got a great
sighting at the moment I have got the
boomers and this in coomer's are not
just alone they are together with one of
the a focus they are feeding on a
buffalo at the moment so I think a
buffalo is a very good-sized animal for
this kind of a group to feed on they can
see we put one beautiful male day so his
head is just in the Buffalo so
everything still looks fresh but it
seems like these animals are too fast to
take to finish this Buffalo so there's
quite a lot of growling at the moment so
there's quite a lot of intraspecific
competition competition which involves
the same kind of species
I listen to that
so this male is growling all the time
so you can see that this one a female
with some kind of a mange so that kind
of female doesn't really belongs to this
pride so it's one of those two females
who are trying to force themselves to
their pride so this is something very
rare because normally a pride of the
Lions the membership doesn't change it
only changes when there's a death or
when there's a born of a cub but here we
can see that there is some other females
that are coming from outside but it
seems like these females are not really
welcomed because every time they try to
avoid them
Ruby look at that so his main is looking
very very very big and is looking very
nice but you can see that he is much
powerful and what he's doing now is what
excited these females the most when it
comes to the mating activities so just
one charge all the females backed off
look at that this is quite a very
beautiful male so they're trying to get
some piece of meat in between the ribs
ii see these two are charging each other
there's quite a lot of wind but I can
hear animal growling it is quite a
lovely sound if you look at what that
male is doing now he is licking his lips
so the tongue of these male lions are so
very much the tongues of the cats
specifically they are very much cause so
they can be able to scrub out some meat
just by licking the ribs so look at that
one
I think there is still quite a lot of
meat so you can see that the one that is
feeling on the left it looks like a a a
female and it is a very big male much
more on the right
so one of the main it is part of the man
gaining pride so the second one I'm not
seeing it here that is the only one I'm
seeing but I'm sure the second one is
here as I saw them few days ago the way
all together so I can see this quite a
lot of dragging at the moment and the
Oklahoma's are not feeding at the moment
so now let's go to a James who's got
Tinga and I was also having something to
eat
although Chiana did not catch is
something for Hassan well he's dropped a
little piece of something for poor
little husana who is now eating what
looks to be the what's the radius and
ulna of a an Impala that's all he's got
so you can imagine not a lot of flesh on
the fore leg of an Impala cow were you
sorry and parlour you I think that's
what he dropped and husana the well
should we say if a patient dies but he
is very patient you know he's very
good-natured most of the time so the
ever patient wasana has now got a little
bit of sunday tea not much though not
enough and obviously some of it he
doesn't really like he's trying to spit
it out houghton gone has managed to sit
up in that beastly uncomfortable tree
all day long stuffing his belly which
must be beastly full right now I just
don't know I think it's very impressive
sorry I went silent there briefly
because Brindley a Smith just came over
the game drive radio asking if there is
a child on game drive who had lost a
Batman mask which was not something you
hear every day
certainly I now have a picture of Brenda
Smith wearing a Batman mask in my mind
well there is ting gana you can't
actually see him he doesn't look
uncomfortable at all he has eaten a huge
amount in the last little while killed
an Impala on his own ate it all stole
this Impala from husana when it was well
I don't know about six hours old Hasan
is now looking like he might try and
climb up but I don't think he will Aiden
only in very extreme circumstances could
11 hurt its tooth biting a bone there
are very very strong teeth Aiden and
you'll find that unless there is some
kind of disease or crack in the tooth
then it's very unlikely that they will
break but when they get older when
they're about the same age is Dingaan Oh
who's now for almost 13 you'll find that
the teeth become blunter but seldom do
they break you do find cats with broken
teeth and that's normally look at your
sana here that's normally because the
tooth that's broken got a disease the
nerve died or something like that became
infected and that then made it weaker
and that's why they break their teeth
are very very strong even stronger than
ours and you know how hard your teeth ID
he's looking so longingly up towards his
dad every time his dad notices image
starts to growl sorry young fellow so
much of your hard work has come to feed
your father that's okay you can do the
same one day when you're a daddy so much
like he's thinking about going up the
tree I don't believe he'll dare to go up
there like he's begging says Sebastian
yeah he does rather look like he's
begging I have to agree sniffing around
maybe there's another mortal that's
dropped if you just work out that tandy
is across the way really not far from
here two hundred meters or so maybe a
hundred meters niala well I think he'd
been business
little fellas going to have a scratch
and then I suspect a snooze let's head
across to his potential thieving station
well there's a potential I suppose
thieving station is not going on around
this area you can see little flair
lumbers up on the bank at the moment
just watching arts and around and pretty
much looking in the direction of where
James is with Dingaan and husana I mean
they're quite a far away away there's
about a hundred meters from where she is
mom is behind her somewhere there it's
kind of you can see she twists her head
every now and then to where mommy's mom
is up on the termite mound probably
using the termite mound is a very good
vantage point because for two reasons
she can once you can seating on up in
the tree the second reason is she'll be
able to spot anything that really comes
towards her kill her kill will be down
below her in the sort of drainage
section then it will allow her to be
able to actually really see what's going
on in and keep a close eye on not only a
kill but Columba as well as any other
potential predators that could be moving
into the area that could be dangerous
for both her own safety as well as her
cubs safety so even though she's
provided a meal it's still a lot of
danger that she has around her and she's
gonna have to be very aware of what's
going on but doesn't Columba look like a
little princess sitting like that she I
know doesn't look like shangela but she
reminds me of shangilia at this age for
some reason I don't know why it is just
that pose that she's got at the moment
it was very much like harshing Lila was
when she was kind of just before she
disappeared had a very similar kind of
way of sitting on termite mounds and
sort of looking around and being quite
sort of stately about it now I believe
some of you have been asking why we sort
of stay with the sightings like what
we've had just had with that new island
and you know the fetus and being eaten
and I mean I will try and answer it from
my point of view this is in no way the
kind of view of everybody but from my
point of view as to why we sit with
these kind of things and I hope that I'm
not insensitive to anyone but
essentially the reason that we're Archer
is to try and basically give everybody a
glimpse into the lives of animals that
is a very short glimpse I mean we gates
only six hours of a 24-hour period so
for 18 hours a day these animals
I'm pretty much doing whatever they need
to be doing and so that's percentage of
time that we spend with them you're so
small and that when things happen we try
and spend time with it not only to to
watch what the process is and for all of
you at home to be able to learn but also
to be able to try and kind of learn from
what the animals do themselves and to
get to know these animals and how they
go about living in their world now
sometimes it's going to be epic happy
cute moments like the first time we met
Columba other times it's going to be
very sort of intense in moments like
this morning with Hassan and tungee and
that confrontation that they kind of had
and in other times it's going to be sad
and difficult to watch like what we've
just seen now now all of those kind of
things combined in together to make
nature nature and it's a reason why
everybody that watches this I hope
everybody that watches us is brought in
by that they were fascinated by the
natural world and the natural world has
epic beautiful moments it was so has
very difficult in the car moments and
those to emerge at times into areas and
while kind of going and watching some of
them it's it's for me a little bit naive
to turn a blind eye to things that are
difficult to watch because it is stilled
an animal's life it is still the way
these animals interact with their
environment and we spend lots and lots
of time trying to kind of spend time
with these animals so that we can all
learn from it in myself included every
other guides here is probably the same
is that we you know we like to try and
spend as much time as we can a certain
animal with all animals I suppose and
try and kind of learn about nature
whether it's hard to watch or not it's
it's sometimes just the way it is and
you know it's a reason why we often kind
of say to people that it's it's a bit
too sensitive and enter all the turn
away the feeding off of a carcass and
particularly one that features a little
fetus is is never easy to watch but it
is also very educational it's it's in
many respects it shows you how a lipid
goes about feeding what organs it will
start to go for how muscle structures
broken down on that animal what the
techniques are in order to be able to
stop it being stolen from them like tiny
just nice you scraped a whole bunch of
soil and and debris over the top of that
after she finished eating in order to
try and just cover that st. up a little
bit and those are things that we would
never really know if we didn't sit
through the ugly parts and so as much as
it's difficult and I know a lot of you
kind of Express that difficulty I hear
you and I understand it and I and I am
sympathetic towards where you're coming
from
but for me the magic of what safari life
is is that the magic of what safari life
is is for everybody to experience
everything Archer and whether you're
somebody that doesn't like it then like
I say we try and give as much of a
warning as we can that people can then
look away during those periods whereas
there are people out there that would be
interested in that process and that's
whole kind of change of and process of
that animal being broken down whether it
be by Leopard hyena vultures whatever it
may be and and there are a lot of
animals that die arches it's only the
way it has to be before all of these
predators to survive and for us to have
a magic moments of Columbia and Changi
playing its required energy to have gone
into a cure and for them to feed on it
and so that process of watching all of
that it's just part and parcel of their
life and and like I said I don't mean to
sound insensitive to those of you that
do kind of have a little bit of a sort
of stand or for nuts and off but it's a
sort of hesitancy to watch something
like that it's by all means your own
choice I'm just trying to put it in from
my point of view as to why we sit with
animals on carcasses and why we watch it
and I know this afternoon it's been a
pretty macabre afternoon in many
respects we've got three different
sighting or four different sightings I
suppose of animals being being fed upon
and and it is difficult to watch and you
know a lot of you will think that has
guides that will sometimes such a Mb you
know you know you will think that us as
guides are stone hearted when it comes
to these kind of things seeing a little
baby in your like that is never pleasant
it's not something that I go out and
thrilled to see it's just part of what
my job is and being able to show you
guys the raw part about it is is what
makes like I say this so special now
case if you can just repeat the name for
me sorry I just got the dream part I
didn't get the the first parts of it
so tears from a dream you say this is
all about nature and this is kind of the
raw part about it and it is sometimes
difficult to watch and difficult to
process but like I said that's what for
me makes this particular sort of job
that I do and this program that we're
part of that you guys are able to watch
so special is that we were able to kind
of show you guys pretty much everything
that goes Archer weather like I say it's
a roller trying to swallow a frog or you
know a liquid eating an unborn fetus it
kind of all fits in at some point and
and it's something that we all kind of
you know like I said I understand where
people come from but I'm just trying to
give it from my side and as to why we
kind of do it now clambers move it
officer let's get on to happier things
let's try and sort of worm our way
through to see where exactly these two
have gone and while I do that to send
you back across to Sydney who's still
with those lions
so you can see that I'm still here with
the Lions now these lions are divided
into many groups there's two males one
Avoca male and one man Guinea from the
Hmong Guinea pride they are feeding on a
buffalo carcass and the rest of the umas
are much more heading towards chitwa
chitwa and with me here is one of the
young males I think who is also slowly
moving following the others but he's got
quite a lot of interest to join the
other males behind what I'm going to do
now is that I am going to leave this
male here and carry on down to try and
see what the Puma females are looking
for they are heading much more down
towards the cheetah little area let's do
that so they are not walking very fast
they are working very very slow I will
find them right somewhere in front here
so maybe now it's time for them to have
something to drink maybe else they they
had enough because when I was looking at
the stomachs I could see that these
females they they really had a lot to
eat you will see when I come across them
again maybe that was one of the
challenges so I'm not too sure who got
there first
but maybe the females were there before
the mayors because this is pride so now
let's go to Egypt now let now I believe
that earlier on today a hyena did come
into this area and husana chased it away
got interesting he or she appears to
have returned and is behind the thicket
now we've driven into this area because
we thought we might get a slightly
better view of the two cats which we
have got here comes a hyena now there we
are
let's just watch how this plays aren't
because of that scavenger tries to take
something that horsey you come to asana
hosannas up and stalking stretching
first but if the hyena tries to take
something that falls which hasana could
have there will be trouble gone husana
don't stand for this don't put up with
this go on here we go see what he does
again every time the hyena turns its
back or sonic gets up and prepares to
charge hyenas it hasn't looked towards
him at all there no there we go well
done Oh sana but you see I got there and
then didn't really know what to do so he
had a bit of a hiss and then the hyena
moved off but it's not like he charged
in and started swatting at him with his
claws if the hyena had pushed back I
suspect wasana may have climbed up the
tree they may have had to deal with his
father yeah no he's to chase the high
unit I think we're gonna move
I'm just gonna take me a couple of
minutes to get out of here I can see him
he's chased across the road I can still
see in there he's on a termite mound
he's running now oh sorry everybody
this really is a rather nasty patch of
ground to being careful Sebastian you
can see the hyena running they're kind
of running around the termite mom trying
to avoid each other we're going to try
and avoid being well wasted upon biting
Ghana we're right underneath him now
hyenas back husana still stalking him
there's husana still stalking the hyena
this high in an ass knows he's being
stalked there he is you can see him
moving there just a little flicker of
spots here he comes out the other side
hyenas skulking off down the road maybe
he's hoping his father will thank him
for chasing away the scavenger
well saunas now moving into the cover of
the bush on the side of the road
ray I think he's more than daddy's food
god I think he's daddy's food provider
and now God
now that hyena could inadvertently be
chased straight on to Tandy's kill I
think let's follow him SIB just in case
he disappears into the gully here that's
very nice
interesting to see and that's chilly
chilly afternoon
well sauna what are you doing please
don't go that way because if you go
crossing this river bed towards tündi
it's going to be very difficult to
follow you it's not a game path still
stalking he's got very bored waiting for
his food what he seem down there the
hide he went off to his right hand side
a lovely picture there
I always think it's situations like this
that a male leopard weeny leopard
actually it's just so I don't know
there's something incongruous about them
in this environment they're just almost
look like they don't fit they're so
magical
he's still heading down towards the
riverbed
he's just tripped now you can see James
was right near at that high end it just
gives you an idea of how close that
caucus is to where we are the sign is
found this caucus and I'm afraid Tandy
was bound to lose it to one or the other
now I'm wondering if she's going to come
in and try and stop this because Claire
lumber is not far she's about I would
say ten meters behind that push they're
just watching over in the most gorgeous
afternoon light look at that she's very
pretty and undies a little bit further
away and I wouldn't be surprised if
Tandy comes flying in here to try and
kind of see if she can get this carcass
away but in the end it's probably too
heavy for her to hoist anyway and so
she's gonna have to just watch as this
hyena tears into this and basically just
eats that you know how i mean--is can be
they will just devour all of this and
they will get really a lot of it done
it's unbelievable kind of how much they
can fit in now this particular line has
got a bit of a belly on it already and
so it's tolerance for the amount of
flesh it can actually pop into its
stomach will be quite interesting I'm
pretty sure that it's not gonna be able
to take as much as it normally would but
it's going to be interesting to see how
much is left I wouldn't be surprised by
eanes have a food guy here eat and once
it's finished that you find tiny coming
in and trying to just take whatever the
leftovers on our lumbers laid on I can't
see where ten years I haven't seen her
lurking at all I'm hoping she will
arrive through because otherwise she's
going to have lost this I'm afraid and
you can see Columbus looking actually
unimpressed by all of this as why is
this kind of carcass been sitting now
Francis you say what a drive it's chaos
it's absolutely sort of cares we've got
lions that are all over the show you
know who knows what's going on with him
at the moment that are all interacting
we've got two male if it's only kill
we've got two female lipids on the kill
and now a hyena that's kind of
interacted on both lipid kills here
comes husana here's a sauna so asanas
found this carcass and look at him he's
gonna try and age forward now it's gonna
be interesting as you see Columbus run
away she immediately ran out of the way
this is ridiculous
now we're gonna hold up speaking because
I'm going to try and take this to a
wider audience as soon as we can I
wonder if Tony's gonna come in right now
welcome to South Africa it is an epic
start to our after all to our evening
should I say as you can see there's a
tug of war between a hyena and a leopard
so what's happened here is a female
leopard killed and Nala and her niqab
have been feeling during the afternoon
but not more than 150 meters away was
two male leopards that also had a kill
and one of the male leopard says run in
here with lion and they've stolen this
kill and they are now having a tug of
war between the two of them this is
absolutely insane now I wonder if the
females going to come back this way or
are we going to see maybe the other male
also arriving here because the other
male is a much bigger male than this one
this young male is called husana and the
bigger male is Tenggara who's his dad
and he might arrive with the noise of
these two feeding and fighting you might
find that that other male comes in but
look at how the hyenas still eating even
though the lipid is trying to drag it
away from it and hyenas going to use all
of its power and strength to be able to
try and kind of break this open and pull
this and try and get as much out of this
carcass as possible
now it really is quite amazing to see
these two penises going at a tug of war
between them now the male leopard is
gonna try and grab as much as he can and
try and maybe get it up into a tree so
even if it's a chunk or a piece of it
he's gonna try and get as much as he can
up there or he's gonna sit and just feed
right next to this I know this is
absolutely ridiculous how amazing is
that now this is just inside we have
four leopards and I ena all in the same
place and I wonder where the other two
leopards have run off to I wonder if
maybe mom has got enough rights and her
cub of shut off and gone in a different
direction it wouldn't surprise me at all
they ran off sort of up north away from
us and so I wouldn't be surprised if the
two of them are trying to get out of
here as quick as possible with hyenas
and other leopards around and mum will
always be very very careful of her cub
and
and kind of separate them but just
listen to the noise of these guys
actually feeding I don't know if you can
hear it heinous jaws are so powerful
it's just breaking open that ribcage and
trying to get into where the flesh is
and you can see why they can make short
work but look at how close that lipids
faces to the hyena isn't this insane
this is absolutely ridiculous now this
is not something you're gonna see every
day we've been absolutely spoiled by
seeing this now it is a reminder that
you can ask questions and you can post
any comments you can just do that in the
comment section below I also haven't
introduced myself my name is Tristan and
on camera now I've got a sensor this
afternoon it is a very warm welcome and
I hope that you're going to enjoy this
is insane amounts of action that is
taking place it's very very very cool to
kind of see what's going on now I am
very surprised if they had the big mail
doesn't arrive yeah I'll be shocked if
he doesn't and the reason why is the
other big mail was finishing up they
kill that he had and so he'll hear this
crunching he'll hear this interaction
and I will just keep an eye and a sort
of head on a swivel just in case he
comes flying out of the bush and arrives
at this particular carcass and we see
him or say interacting because if he
runs in now wouldn't be surprised that
Dinah and this leopard runs away
immediately I'm just listening because I
can hear some alarm calls I wonder if
he's on his way
so Emery if the reason why Hasan is not
attacking 9 is because the line is still
dangerous to him a bite from one of
those well from a hyenas jaws could very
well clash onto his paw and could break
bones in his poor remember their bow in
a mouth structure is hugely powerful I
mean you can see how this hyena is
ripping into this carcass and taking off
big chunks and breaking bone and that
means that Hassan has got to be a bit
careful of that he doesn't want to get
himself injured much easier for him to
be able to find another meal than it is
to be able to try and he
to react with something like a hyena so
he's really got to be very careful about
that and that's why he's just gonna try
and kind of feed next to it and what's
eventually gonna happen is that hyenas
gonna get full and might just leave a
piece or they're gonna have a tug of war
in the caucus who's going to break and
Hassan is gonna end up with one section
and iene is going to end up with the
other section but they both in a race to
try and eat as much as possible
unfortunately for husana Nina's got a
better ability to be able to just
swallow massive chunks of meat but this
is insane it's amazing how quickly Hina
goes through a carcass it astounds me
when they do this look at that
they are almost nose-to-nose Dingaan is
coming now the big males here so the big
male leopard is also coming in here we
go now
this is gonna be there we go you see see
now look there we go he definitely is
going to be the bus you can see how
husana ran away straight away the hyenas
gone and now look at him taking it up
now he is coming back as well he's gonna
try and get it this is just insane now
the hyenas grab the fetus from this baby
I'm war baby gnyana that there it was
inside the mother they goes Dianna
husana unfortunately is lost art butts
in Ghana has got it up in a tree here's
Tandy now there's the third leopard here
comes Tandy as well so he is the mother
she's also here so we've got the mother
we've got two asana coming in three
lipids in the same place look at this
this is insane
now Tandy is moving off she's calling
her cubs she's trying to get a cub to
try and say come let's get out of here
there's too many leopards around there's
too much going on and so she's trotting
off husana is going to the base of the
tree to try and see if he can find some
food this is insane
now can you believe what is going on
here this is ridiculous this is not
something that you are going to see
every day there's two big male lipids
well one very big male leopard and one
still growing lipid in one frame and
Tanvi in the background some way off to
the left you might be able to just see
her moving so three lipids in one shot
which is not what you see very often
especially three adult lipids like what
we're seeing now the cub is run off the
cob would have run off in this commotion
she's gonna try and got in some ways
safe I wouldn't even be surprised that
that little cub is
in a tree somewhere just trying to stay
out of the way of this chaos but you can
see it in ganas power he just ran in you
see how that I in a mediately saw wait
this is not a young lipid like the one
I've been dealing with and that's why
he's literally just kind of everyone let
go and ran often ganas running grabbed
it and taken it and now what's
interesting is that you see look at in
ganas actually urinating so urinating
from the tree is what he's doing so he's
st. marking even from up there telling
all of these leopards and hyenas this is
his domain all of you back off you can
see the dribbling coming down a little
bit it's not easy to see kind of the
background is difficult but there you
can just kind of see it coming down a
little bit so that's him telling
everybody this is my caucus this is my
area all of you back off and wow that
went from north to 100 in about five
seconds all of a sudden we were sitting
here and there was no leopards on this
carcass there was a little cub that was
just watching from further away about a
year old he wasn't a kind of doing
anything and all of a sudden hyena first
then husana linton ghana
and now mom is also running in the form
of Tandy this is just insane
now for those of you who've never been
to kind of joined us before and watching
this chaos unfold I can
is a very interesting situation what we
actually have is a lipid kind of family
tree here so their lipid right in the
top of the tree he's the big guy in this
area and the dominant male he's called
Singh Ghana and he is quite an old male
he's about 12 years old and he is the
father of the liquid that is below him
called hisana
who is a male that is about two years
and eight months and he is still growing
and still finding his feet at the moment
dad is very tolerant of him but he is
still kind of you know figuring things
out
now the other lipid which is the female
her name is Tandy and she's the older
sister of husana so she's about 12 years
old much the same age as in Ghana and
she they have the same mother husana and
Tandy and ting Ghana has fathered
Tandy's cub as well as rasayana so it's
a very complicated mix it's all kind of
linked together and they've all kind of
sort of joined in this one area which is
just insane Wow Giselle you're saying
you're trying to find one word for the
sighting but it's too difficult
I know it's just absolute pandemonium is
what I would probably say for one word
it's insane to see what has just taken
place these are not things you get to
see every single day you you go a long
time in life going through to the bush
and and visiting and being a guide
before you'll see a sighting like what
we've just witnessed that amazing kind
of rush in from these lepers you can see
look at him he's up there now what's
interesting is this is the second kill
he's stolen sedating on a stole her son
is killed this morning so husana had a
different kill further away about 150
meters away and he stole that and he's
now stolen another kill from poor husana
and so you know it's just a game of
thievery at the moment and it's been
like this through the whole winter with
these particular lipids we've been
seeing this regularly that they all kind
of are thieving from one another and
it's become all of a bit of a mess but
anyway there goes a sauna he see he's
trying to see if maybe that carcass
drops that he can grab some of it
ting Ghana's trying to steadily put it
back into the tree this
is absolutely ridiculous Wow is all I
can say now it's going to take a bit of
time for everyone to settle it will all
settle down eventually you will find
that everyone will find the place that
they want to be in and everyone will
kind of relax a little bit but it's
going to take a little time it's been a
sudden it's close kind of moment of
complete chaos anyway it's been an
absolute pleasure having you guys on
board we're going to sign off for now I
hope that you enjoyed that moment of
pandemonium and we'll hopefully see you
all again on safari live if you want to
see what plays out remember that you can
just google Safari live and carry on
watching us but from scenes and myself
it's been an absolute pleasure we'll see
you all soon
well how was that that was absolutely
insane we have just been witness to one
of those very special moments in the
bush and and this is part of what goes
through what we were talking about
earlier is that's actually spending time
watching an animal eats a carcass
sometimes these are the things that kind
of take place and interactions and
behavior that we wouldn't have witnessed
had we left that all alone so very very
special to see what we've just seen well
I need to catch my breath that was all a
bit chaotic to be honest and so
hopefully it kind of settles down a
little bit but it is that time though
that we are going to be signing off
remember we are going to be coming to
you again at 6:30 our time or central
african time we lead kickoff as a
premier on local south african
television so remember to tune in again
in about half an hour's time and
hopefully the madness will be continuing
at that stage it's going to be certain
is lined up to be an action-packed
evening so from all of us that have been
out this afternoon it's been an absolute
pleasure hopefully we'll see you a
little bit later otherwise we'll see you
tomorrow morning on the Sunrise Safari